hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oh my god oh sweet
Jesus did you dis by half of the
department store honey you don't even
know yet if it's gonna be a boy or a
girl
I was gonna say they're gonna be
adorable but I sensed you were being a
little bit of a douche so I don't know I
I loved children's shoes or just a bit
eat I love tiny versions of things
that's why I like tiny buxom so much but
anyway welcome back to layers of fear I
can't wait to keep moving forward I'm
gonna try to not be such a giant post
about this and actually move forward at
a good clip not hesitate everywhere I go
oh is this gonna be an outlast situation
laughter gonna foger I don't even know
if this game is actually complete it
might not be because it is an early
access so it might not be the end of the
game but I'm gonna go as far as I can
and what are we doing what did I do
wrong oh I need to close the door bro
there we go take me away take me away to
a special place take me away
excuse me excuse me oh wow
I've seen this elevator scenario before
in a few other games like there was that
one oculus rift game Africa affected I
believe it was I'll like it in the
description if I find it it was an
oculus rift game and it was very much
based on the elevator thing like he
started out on a floor nyet to send into
the get very spoopy very spoopy very
jump scary but you know the oculus rift
or games kind of were that's what they
were about okay yeah they're actually
stopped being a lot of development in
the Akio no no no no no no no no don't
do that to me
oh hi oh hi oh god you dick freakin dick
dick I don't like this stupid I hate
this
Stallman I hate it it's dominated all
this dumb and I hate it oh I hate this
well why did you stop that dude was
perfect honey please just a little
longer at least until we finish painting
this one part oh don't make me beg I'm
gonna look up it's gonna be different
okay Oh standing okay
hello Oh No
what are you changing to okay right is
that all is that all okay good I'll just
okay bye then
I thought something was gonna happen I
said I was gonna stop being such a giant
puss that starts right now
here we go hi who's here who wants some
I got a fistful of [ __ ] you and
yeah you better run a-hole go to hell if
I'm not already there
Oh am I drunk
can I just not see the end of hallway I
should've done that oh oh well that's no
good
it's uh not good it's exactly not good
there lots of whispers okay bye-bye
doggies
oh poor jeez I love dog you so much
hello hi who's there
yes can I help you I'm going insane okay
Oh No what did I just leave undone it
cannot be undone I didn't know what I
was doing but I know I was doing okay
apparently a fire hapless no-good yes
because what what fire oh oh oh God God
is she she which hospitals I'm on my way
yeah I connected the dots there I
figured out what happened but so why
can't I be undone yeah it sure can
oh boy so so am i a douche am I actually
a douche or am I what did I actually you
[ __ ] you get out of here there's
nothing yet so this uh alright let's try
this again finally managed to play a
little
if banging on the keys awkwardly counts
is playing I won't lie it drives me
insane to not have full control of my
fingers in any case I was promptly
berated by my loving husband who said I
should be resting I know he means well
but how will I ever get better if I
don't work at it the worst thing is I
could swear I smelled liquor on his
breath please God please not this game
okay so those are letters from my wife I
can't get in here make up your mind
oh that's bizarre oh no I am a douche
she must have had burns and then I
thought she was pretty before and then
what I didn't think she was pretty again
after probably what a dick bag what a
douche nozzle
be we okay
I remember you gonna do something this
time probably oh you dick uh you dickbag
you dick hole you douche you douche
nozzle
you douche a donger okay all right where
am I going
what am i doing where did I come from
where to go where to come from
cotton-eye Joe apparently someone told
me that that that song is actually about
an STD is that what it is cuz if that I
don't know if someone was just
bullshitting me on that one but if
somebody is that's is what it about who
more knows today even worse than before
the sad part is I agree with every word
more notes from my lovely wife oh boy
charging blindly forward because I am so
brave charging light be forward to step
into my grave Oh charging blindly
forward oh my [ __ ] you [ __ ] you oh my
lovely wife oh my lovely Muse how I wish
you to be whole again and I wish not to
be a douche what happen did we have a go
Kyle [ __ ] you I thought it was gonna
happen again you want this as well oh I
guess I'm just an innocent bystander
wanna forgive my a part of this
oh [ __ ] you well this is totally Petey
right here no I'm coming in there why
don't you run away from me excuse my
prepubescent squeaking voice well I'm
coming in there Oh God what's doing this
oh now or now or now
I'm gonna light this up get a little
light in here mood lighting from love to
madness man apprehended after kidnapping
his own daughter oh man yeah removed
from his care after a Family Court
ruling after unsuccessful attempts
fearing that the man might art the child
okay this says a lot of things this
definitely says some things this guy's
uh not uh not coping well not coping
well okay I'll just go this right now
hello friend
was there something no come on what am I
supposed to do it's all blocked off is
there something else in here that I
needed little brother okay all right
okay don't do that to me don't do that
to me the sound just suddenly dropped
off the radar oh oh there we go okay I
got thought I saw a leg oh I thought I
saw a leg
oh god no no oh no oh no we're clear you
oh don't thank you I don't want any Girl
Scouts not welcome here Oh Oh God
oh-oh-oh we climbed into the painting
this looks bright and nice
okay cool that's good that's good
prosthesis Snatchers why the damn leg
insatiable bastards can't afford a new
one uh maybe you should make good art
you wash up nobody maybe you should be a
little braver oh I get it I'm good to
put a thing on the thing I did a bad
thing
oh no I didn't mean what are you gonna
do come on bring it on so what's
happening to is happening to it
now that was so weird I thought it was
morphing like ours I was moving did it
just do a smooth transition there what
oh my god oh my god everything's
starting to paint it's so symbolic don't
do that no no no no no no no no no okay
all right you want to fight fight bro
and a plastic tubing for blood siphon I
gasped before I knew how it was done are
you talking about blood the tube in a
vein and sucked on it until blood filled
my mouth then put the tube in the jar
and it just kept coming the taste of
copper haunted me the entire night why
think of a surreal
okay I don't know why did you decide to
paint with blood that seems like your
first mistake okay can I get out of here
now how do I get out of here how do I
get out of here oh here are you out of
your gun I didn't see that what did the
doctor just say about straining yourself
you can barely hold a cone leave that
damn thing alone yeah I'm kind of a
douche aren't I taking away all hope
that's definitely the right thing to do
in these situations
okay so what about that now this is
really quiet in here wait was this oh oh
oh oh if I played in forward okay I
didn't know I can control it I stepped
right on ah
that's working okay oh that's so cool
that's actually pretty cool that's cool
mechanic oh that's so weird
that's so cool oh that's so cool oh I
can't wait for this game to rob me of a
sense of wonder okay I don't know if I
found everything I found like another
thing I don't know if I'm nearly to
everything hello how's it going that
blood flamingoes gonna change
yoki
I don't know what that is it looks fun
though
good job mr. Artie pants oh look and now
you're painting with blood now you're
thinking with blood okay so that's cool
for this episode thank you everybody so
much for watching I can't wait to dive
deeper into mattis's I play the rest of
this game so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I'll see you
in the next video
Wow